a typical Sunday for some 40 million
Nigerians welcoming teams are sure
people into one of the roughly 500
Pentecostal churches in the country I'm
joining a service today in one of these
mega churches just outside of Lagos it's
the third biggest one in Nigeria the
service starts all too rather quietly
but people don't stay in their seats for
long
[Music]
the pastor calls himself a bishop here
and he celebrated like a star David oil
deep was estimated birth is 150 million
u.s. dollars many of his followers
yearned for that kind of wealth
Europe was prosperity gospel resonates
with the big donation baskets fill
quickly the belief is the more you give
during and after the church service the
more your wealth filling clicks after
church there are many more ways to spend
money
how about olive oil sold for five US
dollars per bottle this is not to eat it
is to put on your head why why is not
it's because the blessed oil like it is
not like normal random oil used for
cooking or for anything but once you
believe and you use the oil swap for you
its cure sickness is its Casuarina
stickers anything people have been
healed from HIV by using justice oil
Pentecostal churches compete for members
each promises economic salvation a
solution and people want to believe in
them especially in times of hardship God
Jesus that's also the first billboard
you see when you enter the University of
Lagos France is Falak oh is a professor
of religious studies
he says Nigeria is one of the most
religious countries in Africa but he's
concerned about the focus of Pentecostal
churches
he's dangerous because theologically
everything revolves around a pastor and
then the tendency is to shift you know
focus on the pastor and then not on God
number one and the lifestyle of the
pastor becomes this turn that not that
of Christ he says people's faith is
being exploited and converted into a
commercial business to the price tag
most of these pastors are not there to
serve they are there to enrich
themselves
okay and when you question some of their
practices okay then we quote the Bible
to support themselves Jesus was not born
Jesus are the best of these they are the
best of that churches are not required
to pay taxes but we'd arise in extreme
poverty so politicians want to change
that still it's a highly unpopular idea
among those who believe positive change
is only possible through their faith and
not their government